the actor producer also ballers by the
way season 2 coming up premieres Sunday
night on HBO and mark joins us are you
in Detroit right now I am I am it's my
afternoon now I woke up at 4:00 to Train
teed off at Knollwood country clubs
played in an hour and 40 and then
heading off to work for a 12-hour day
what did you shoot shot 78 I made two
birdies amid double bogeys but we played
fast though and now I didn't didn't hit
a single ball on the range right to the
tee after an hour and 20 minute workouts
it'll kick the crap out of you does the
rock play I've never played with him
I've never seen him play club I when we
shot together doing a painting game I
had only played once and we were lifting
so much weights it you know lifting
weights like that and bodybuilding is
not good for golf swing so I didn't play
but I never never I wouldn't be
surprised
well you get guys who were muscle
muscle-bound I played with Eddie George
one time and Eddie George thought
because he was so much bigger than me
that he should be able to hit it past me
and it drove him crazy and I said dude
it's not about your muscles it's what
you it's what you do with your muscles
in your swing well look at Bubba Watson
skinnier the ramp a mile do you think
Tigers to muscle-bound
because I think he was training in a way
where it was mostly you know just core
strength and functional movement stuff
so I don't think he was used to strong I
said God you know if you train the right
way and do a lot of rotational stuff you
know then I think it's good for the game
if I'm curious with the NFL and has the
NFL reacted to ballers at all oh yeah
absolutely I mean I remember Pete
calling me saying we have to get on the
phone with Roger Goodell because there's
no funny because without your eyes
the first reason to get cameos and then
by the time the show is established
you'd have people calling and then we
had to kind of start over with ballers
people didn't really know what it was
and then the first call we were getting
was from higher-ups in the NFL talking
about how they didn't like shell but
thankfully thankfully concussion came
out took all that attention away from us
and and then you're able to kind of just
continue the ask Roger Goodell phonetic
cameo on the show I think you do a great
job
is there a ton is there a topic where
you've gone nope that's that's too crazy
too dark make as realistic as possible
but you know you kind of show the ups
and downs the fun side of it I was it
set in Miami so it's it's sexy and cool
and these guys you know come into a lot
of money but there's also a lot of
there's a lot of downside there well you
know we don't I wouldn't say we stay
away from anything but we don't want
just push down on the looks a crucial
piece Mark Wahlberg tune in for season 2
executive producer of HBO series ballers
that'll be 10 p.m. Eastern on HBO you
following the Brady drama day one of
course like everybody else
should the Supreme Court hear this case
um you know I look I'm for my own
selfish reasons
absolutely but there's a lot of other
crazy stuff going on you think about
where we are the country's probably a
lot more important things to focus on
but it is what it is I think you know
we're gonna be okay regardless the
picture is going to use it as fuel
Garoppolo go out there win three games
or maybe win four games I mean if we
cannot beat the Cardinals you know
pitchers gotta catch em they got it
obviously changed change the offense you
know it'll be a little bit more mobile
and you know get time back healthy and
also they used it as fuel a little 12
and for that a good chance of being in a
Super Bowl winning it again so how did
the Patriots affect your day like a
Sunday if you're watching her Monday
whenever they're on if they win tonight
have it
if they win everybody in the house gets
whatever they want cars included yes
they lose my wife won't speak to me
fully everybody knows to stay away um
and you know she said to me before it's
only a game and that that didn't go over
well but I try I honestly do try to just
let it go and look at it that it's only
a game I it but you know what you're
still passionate about them and you know
you you must know only happiness and joy
on their failure success so much so it's
one of those things where I try not to
let it get to me but you can't halt it
usually takes a while to shake up
especially if they lose you know they
lost AFC championship last year that
that really hurt that took a couple
weeks but who hurts you more like you
get more joy out of one and one hurts
you more if I said Red Sox or or
Patriots I had pictures absolutely
because the rest look the Red Sox and
loss for so long and now that they got
over the hump
you know beating the Yankees you know
for being down three nothing was the
greatest thing that ever happened and
then after that then winning two more
two more World Series is great but you
know the Patriots are you know football
is the thing you know I won't watch
baseball really other than watch I want
to really want to watch poppy it often
as possible just because you've done so
many great things for the Red Sox for
the city of Boston the state of mastery
for naming New England as a whole and it
was really nice how they treated him at
the all-star game and hopefully we're
gonna see him that final game in New
York and they better stand up and they
better applause well what advice I draw
but what advice would you give him I
mean just have an incredible year it
it's hard to walk away from this you
know what he just seemed I would say
okay if I played that good you know why
not give it another go but everything
I'm here you know he did a small scene
in Patriots taking the AP Berg and each
thing his body's really tired you know
he's heard and he's just kind of running
on fumes um anyone still you know he
wants to be able to move and be healthy
and and I have a life after baseball but
you know I don't know maybe maybe
that'll change
coming fall but you know spring of next
year we'll see how tough was it to shoot
Patriots Day very but also important
I mean it's extremely important you
think about a lot of people were saying
especially in and around the Boston area
that is too soon yeah and Pete and I
were sitting there talking and I said to
Pete I said Pete you think about what's
going on in the world right now you
think of all what happened in these
yesterday and in Brussels and everywhere
else in Orlando it's not too soon it's
almost too late we have to go out there
and continue to say that love will
always conquer hate and good will always
conquer evil we cannot be told how we're
gonna live our lives and we need to be
able to go out there and promote that
and put that message out there and we're
never going to be able to completely
prevent these things from happening but
they're gonna deter us from fighting for
good you know
and so and once we've told people what
we were doing and looking in card I mean
we try to you know communicate that
people will make a little survive and
deep water horizon and when we got to do
that feeling vigils we got to speak to
directly but when people see the movie
they're gonna understand and this movie
is really going to inspire people and so
and to see how people came together in
the face of tragedy when that happened
you know it was amazing to see people
running towards the eventing exposed as
opposed to running away and you know
people coming together and not
conquering so that that's a really
important lesson you could be more time
you felt obligated to do this you had to
do this absolutely and you know it was
one of those things I was like oh you
know and then I don't want to do board
if somebody else does it and they get it
wrong and they don't they don't handle
it with with the delicacy and
sensitivity that it needs to be handled
if they're not paying you know the
Campbell family Lulu family the Collier
family the Richard family is the doubt
from everybody else who's heard out
there on on that day and then I'm paying
them the proper respect and handling
with the sensitive white-glove approach
that they should you know so I felt like
you know what I would take that
responsibility on and
you hold me accountable if we don't get
it right and you know I'm gonna be the
one to hear about it I pride myself on
being able to go home I hold my head up
high and I know Pete was the right guy
for the job
season two of ballers Sunday night at
10:00 Eastern on HBO mark always great
to catch up with you thanks for joining
us Dan you're the best thank you it's
Mark Wahlberg a busy schedule he gets
more done by 7:00 a.m. and I think then
we get done during the day the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience